[Music]
Hollywood movies make people worry about
the wrong things in terms of super
intelligence well we should really worry
about is not malice but competence where
we have machines that are smarter than
us whose goals just aren't aligned with
ours for example I don't hate ants I
don't go out of my way to stomp on an
ant if I see one on the sidewalk but if
I'm in charge of this hydroelectric dam
construction and just as I'm gonna flood
this valley with water I see an anthill
there you know tough luck for the ants
right their goals weren't aligned with
mine and because I'm smarter this could
be my goals not the ants goals that get
fulfilled we never want to put Humanity
in the role of those ants on the other
hand it doesn't have to be bad if you
solve the gold Lymon problem my little
babies tend to be in a household
surrounded by human level intelligence
--is that are smarter than the babies
namely their parents right and that
works out fine because the goals of the
parents are wonderfully aligned with the
goals of the child so the chimp
it's all good and this is one vision
that a lot of AI researchers have the
Friendly AI vision that we will succeed
in not just making machines that are
smarter than us but also machines that
then learn adopt and retain our goals as
they get ever smarter it might sound
easy to get machines to learn adopt and
retain our goals but these are all very
tough problems first of all if you take
yourself driving taxi and tell it in the
future to take you the airport as fast
as possible and then you get there
covered in vomit and chased by
helicopters and you say no no no no
that's not what I wanted and it replies
that is exactly what you asked for
then you've appreciated how hard it is
to get a machine to understand your
goals your actual goals you know a human
cab driver would have realized that you
also had other goals that were unstated
because she was also a human and has all
this shared reference frame but a
machine doesn't have that unless we
explicitly teach it that right and
once the Machine understands our goals
there's a separate problem we're getting
them to adopt the goals anyone who's had
kids knows how big the difference is
between making the kids understand what
you want and actually adopt your goal to
do what you want and finally even if you
can get your kids that Dolf your goals
that doesn't mean they're gonna retain
them for life right my kids are a lot
less excited about Lego now than they
were when they were little and we don't
want machines as they ever get ever
smarter to gradually change their goals
away from being excited about protecting
us and thinking of this thing about
taking care of humanity is just a little
childhood thing like Lego is that they
get bored with eventually if we can
solve all three of these question jizz
getting machines to understand our goals
adopt the man retain them then we can
create an awesome future because
everything I love about civilization is
the product of intelligence then if we
can use machines to amplify our
intelligence then we have this potential
to solve all the problems that are
dumping us today and create a better
future than we even dare to dream of if
machines ever surpass us and can
outsmart us at all tasks that's gonna be
a really big deal because intelligence
is power the reason that we humans have
more power on this planet than tigers is
not because we have larger muscles or
sharper claws it's because we're smarter
than the Tigers and in this exact same
way this machines are smarter than us
it becomes perfectly plausible for them
to control us and become the rulers of
this planet and beyond and when I J good
made this famous analysis of how you get
an intelligence explosion where
intelligence just kept creating greater
and greater intelligence leaving us far
behind he also mentioned that this super
intelligence would be the last invention
that man need ever make and what he
meant by that of course was it so far
the most intelligent being on this
planet that's been doing all the
inventing it's been us but once we make
machines that are better than us at
inventing
all future technology that we ever need
can be created by those machines if we
can make sure that they do things for us
that we want and help us create an
awesome future where humanity can
flourish like never before
[Music]